welcome back to las vegas now it's time
for today's legal minute and attorney
eric palacios from eric palacios and
associates sponsors of this segment
shares the multiple ways one can go
about becoming a legal resident of this
country take a look
hi i'm eric palacios and welcome to the
legal minute today's question is what
are the most common ways to become a
legal resident of the united states or
to get a green card number one through a
relative if you already have a relative
living legally in the united states your
relative can sponsor you a u.s citizen
can immediately sponsor a spouse
unmarried children under the age of 21
and their parents
number two through work if you have a
qualifying job offer if you're moving to
the united states for a permanent job
offer your employer can petition you for
residency
also immigrants who demonstrate an
exceptional ability don't need a sponsor
and they can petition themselves
number three if you're a refugee or an
asylee if you are legally in the united
states as a refugee or through asylum
and have lived in the united states for
at least a year you can petition for
residency don't forget to download my
free app eric palacio's legal app we'll
see you next time
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at 702-444-7777